willkommen zurück bei der These von Il
canypur
ja wir haben acht Monate lang über den
Iran diskutiert und jetzt wo die
Aufmerksamkeit nachlässt niemand mehr
drauf schaut ob Mädchen im Iran in den
Schulen vergiftet werden vergast werden
ob Mädchen vergewaltigt werden lässt die
Aufmerksamkeit nach und es hat eine
hinrichtungswelle begonnen wir haben
zwei deutsche Staatsbürger im iranen
Gefangenschaft und nach kavi das ist ein
Schlag ins Gesicht der leisen Demokratie
der Bundesrepublik ich kritisiere dass
das Auswärtige Amt hier mit zwei Maß
Mist zwischen Putin und ähm dem Iran wir
brauchen an dieser Stelle dürfen wir
nicht die gleichen Fehler machen wie wir
bei Russland gemacht haben autokarten
verstehen nur eine Sprache und neben dem
humanistischen Argumenten verspielt
Europa und Deutschland hier auch eine
einzigartige Chance wird diskutieren ja
häufig darüber dass wir Fluchtursachen
bekämpfen wollen ein demokratisches Iran
könnte die Region komplett neu
stabilisieren wir hätten deutlich
weniger Menschen die fliehen müssten
geopolitisch ist das interessant und
diese Chancen verpassen wir weil Europa
immer nur reagiert anstatt einmal als
agieren zu kommen und von seinen Fehlern
der Vergangenheit zu lernen
selber Schicksale auch vor Ort wo
Menschen auch zum Tode verurteilt wurden
das ist so es ist wir haben im konkreten
Fall Jumpy sharmut das sind Todesstrafe
wir hatten das letzte Mal schon darüber
gesprochen die Todesstrafe wurde jetzt
bestätigt dann deutsche Staatsbürger der
ohne Verschulden im Iran verschleppt
wurden ist der ist in Dubai zwischen
gelandet und wurde entführt und ich muss
sagen wenn die Bundesrepublik die
eigenen Staatsbürger nicht mehr schützen
kann dann haben wir ein Problem und das
ist hat was mit unserer Außenpolitik zu
tun der Iran ist aufgebaut auf geiselt
Diplomatie jedes Mal wenn Sie jemanden
quasi aufgrund von zugeschnitten ist und
Gelder sind oder gefangenenaustausche
freilassen nehmen sie jemand anders um
uns zu erpressen eine Demokratie darf
sich nicht erpressen lassen sie darf
sich nicht an verhandlungsstisch setzen
mit solchen Menschen das haben wir
gelernt dass dieser peace mit Politik
nicht funktioniert das wissen wir später
sind nach Putins einmal Marsch und jetzt
ein eng Verbündeten von Putin an dieser
Stelle nach wie vor dort mit zwei Lamas
zum Essen ist aus meiner sichten Skandal
was würden Sie vorschlagen was kann die
Diplomatie besser machen erstmal muss
die transparent werden wir wissen nicht
mal wie viele deutsche Staatsbürger
derzeit im Gefangenschaft sind es sind
zwei Fälle bekannt es sind weitere Fall
europa muss mit einer Stimme sprechen
was das angeht sonst spielen sie die der
Iran spielt nämlich ganz geschickt die
unterschiedlichen Länder gegeneinander
aus und wir brauchen vor allem ein
klares Signal gegenüber das Regime und
das ist nur die Revolution Garden auf
die Terrorliste zu setzen und hier
spielt das Auswärtige Amt nicht wirklich
transparent ich versuche seit Monaten
herauszufinden wer an dieser Stelle
welches Land und an welchen Gründen aus
welchen Gründen gerade ähm es nicht
passiert und ähm es ist vollkommen
untransparent die Bundesregierung das
Auswärtige Amt spielt auf Zeit Europa
spielt auf Zeit Borell spielt auf Zeit
und das ist keine Neutralität sondern es
ist stabilisierte Faktor das Regime und
ist es passiert vielleicht noch das was
wir von Russland erwartet haben dass
Menschen auf die Straße gehen passiert
dort und sie kämpfen für unsere Werte
dieselben Werte die wir haben und wir
lassen sie gerade im Strich haben Sie
auch schon die Ministerin Arena Werbung
selbst angesprochen ich habe sie eben
ich habe ich spreche regelmäßig mit dem
verschiedenen Abgeordneten
die Abgeordneten sind übrigens näher bei
uns weil sie auch näher an der
Bevölkerung sind
ich habe nicht die Gelegenheit gehabt
bisher mit Frau bärbock direkt zu
sprechen
es gibt Signale innerhalb der
Bundesregierung die ähm die schätze ich
auch aber es reicht bei weitem nicht und
was mich ein Stück weit wundert ist dass
dass sie ja im Falle von Russland sehr
klar war und sehr richtig und ähm in
diesem Fall doch leisere Töne
eingeschlagen das ist übrigens keine
parteipolitische Frage das hat was mit
der deutschen Außenpolitik zu tun da ist
meine Partei nicht besser da ist die
Union Zeiten nicht besser Genscher hat
letztendlich das war das erste
Deutschland das erste Land das dem
Regime die Hand gereicht hat
da haben wir tatsächlich alle eine
gewisse Vergangenheit aber jetzt wo die
Menschen zu 80% gegen das Regime sind
muss man hinter den Menschen stehen und
nochmal es geht nicht nur um humanitäre
Gründe sondern auch in Europas
langfristige Interessen und die
verspielen wir wieder und ich ich sage
Ihnen jetzt schon voraus irgendwann wird
das Regime fallen irgendwann wird hier
etwas passieren leider Gottes
dass iranische Regime operiert auf
europäischen Boden auf deutschen Boden
wir sind alle gefährdet und dann wird
man reagieren und dann hatte man es
nicht vorher gewusst und ich sage ganz
klar die Fakten liegen auf dem Tisch die
Politik muss nur agieren ja
wirtschaftlichen Interessen dahinter
oder warum halten wir uns so in der
außen Diplomatie also ich kann das alles
unterstreichen was Sie gesagt haben aber
sie sind in dieser Materie viel ähm
tiefer drin als ich es bin ich kann nur
feststellen dass der Fokus durch den
Ukraine kriegt natürlich sich vom Iran
ein Stück weit auch verschoben hat
Richtung Ukraine Richtung Russland und
das die krass dieses Terror-Regime im
Iran in gewisser Weise ein Profiteur
dieses russischen Angriffskrieges ist
weil natürlich ein ganz ganz starkes
Blickfeld jetzt Russland und die Ukraine
sind und der Iran da ein bisschen aus
aus dem Blickfeld gerät und natürlich
auch einen zentrales Thema
beispielsweise des Bundeskanzlers und
der Außenministerin die Lösung des
Konfliktes und die Unterstützung der
Ukraine in diesem brutalen Krieg ist und
natürlich auch Kapazitäten fehlen um
sich stärker um den Iran zu kümmern aber
das ist tragisch für die Menschen im
Iran aber das ist bittere politische
Realität Iran liefert aber auch Drogen
Drohnen an Russland also selbst dieser
Konflikt ist da sehr miteinander
verwoben der irrat ist sehr anders
Regime ist sehr nah an Russland und
einen an China angedockt also wir haben
ja auch durch die zeitenwände auch eine
neue geopolitische Lage alleine aus
diesen strategischen Gründen mit
humanistischen Gründen kommt man ja
nicht immer nur weit ähm deswegen
versuche ich zumindest auch diese
Interessen aufzumachen aber da sind wir
ein bisschen zu kurzsichtig und das ist
ein Problem
wir blicken Sie darauf sind die auf die
Innenpolitik bekannt ich habe diesen
Farm mit großer Aufmerksamkeit verfolgt
weil ich selber einige Fälle aus meinem
Wahlkreis hatte in den letzten Jahren
immer wieder Kontakt zum Auswärtigen Amt
in einem Fall zum Bundeskanzleramt da
ist mir immer wieder signalisiert worden
was war jetzt gehen nur nicht an die
Öffentlichkeit die Verwandten die Eltern
die wollen dann natürlich das was
passiert ja gehen nicht an die
Öffentlichkeit wir arbeiten hinter dem
Vorhang wir haben enge Beziehungen zur
Regierung manchmal hat es geklappt
manchmal hat es auch nicht geklappt aber
sie waren viel vorsichtiger nach in der
Öffentlichkeit als dann mir das
auswärtige am glaub paar versichert hat
wir kennen den Fall wir arbeiten dran
deswegen weiß ich nicht was jetzt hinter
den Kulissen passiert und trotzdem ist
völlig richtig dass es auffällt selbst
in China wie klare Worte wir finden
wobei ich nicht glaube dass ich ihn bin
da irgendwie beeindrucken lässt wenn
Frau Berber wieder abgereist ist aber
oder andere Frage wie wir uns andere zur
Brust nehmen übrigens nicht nur Russland
aber beim Iran sagen wir immer noch ja
wir brauchen gute auch wirtschaftliche
Beziehung wir wollen ein
gesprächsfahrten nicht abreißen lassen
und und und und in einem Punkt
allerdings wird mich ihre Einschätzung
interessieren übernehmen wir uns da
nicht wer ist nicht viel wichtiger dass
die Europäische Union wenn wir sogar ein
außen beauftragten in dieser Frage mit
einer Stimme spricht ansonsten besteht
ja immer sie geschehen hat die Gefahr
dass das eine Land diese Politik
betreibt und das andere Land jene wir
müssen da geschlossen agieren aber in
Europa ist ja Deutschland und Frankreich
in der Regel dann doch häufig der Motor
wenn wir die beiden Länder dazu bringen
in die richtige Richtung zu gehen und
die dürfen nicht vergessen Deutschland
hat eine besondere Verantwortung wir
sind wirklich wichtigste Handelspartner
hier wird ganz besonders darauf
hingeschaut und deswegen muss
Deutschland hier eine Führungsrolle
übernehmen sie haben das Thema leise
Diplomatie angesprochen
das funktioniert nicht Ich habe gestern
mit der Tochter von jeanshi Charme hat
noch gesprochen
auch um zu besprechen weil ich
vielleicht auch dieselben Gedanken habe
gefährdet man da jemand gefährdet man
vielleicht sogar jemanden wenn man keine
leisen drin sie sagt genau das Gegenteil
ist der Fall die leise Diplomatie das
nicht in den Mund nehmen dieses des
Namens ihres Vaters hat letztendlich das
Regime noch mehr bestärkt und das ist
das System dieser Geiselwind im
Gegenteil jedes Mal wenn man diese die
Namen der Gefangenen Mund nimmt
Aufmerksamkeit rettet Leben und das
Regime lebt davon von
Ignoranz und das ist ein Dunkelheit
agiert und wir müssen tatsächlich dort
eine klare Linie ziehen wir müssen die
revolutionsgarten auf die Terrorliste
setzen dann hat es wirklich eine Chance
und du wir glauben dass wir neutral sein
können und wir sind wir können gar nicht
mehr neutral sein Neutralität bedeutet
das Regime zu stützen und ähm
Entschuldigung Europäische Union wir die
Europäer ja Deutschland hat hier eine
ganz besondere Verantwortung ganz toll
dass wir darauf aufmerksam machen wollen
und ich finde das ist auch ein ganz toll
Schlusswort zu ihrer These weil das ist
ja auch der Grund warum sie das heute
mitgebracht haben wurden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie